Now we've learned a lot about some basic functions, like this one, y equals x
squared, who's graph is this lovely purple parabola. You also learned about
some other polynomial functions. For example, we have y equals x cubed also,
which produced this really different and really interesting graph. So clearly
the large scale behavior of different functions Is really different on what
their equation looks like. And it also changes from region to region of the
domain. I wonder what would happen if we increased the degree of polynomial
function even more. Like, let's say we have y to the x to the fourth. Well
that's totally different again, that's really interesting. Maybe I'll just get
rid of these two that we already know a lot about and just focus on this one.
Let's do something else, y equals x to the fourth plus. x. Well that's cool.
That's totally different from anything we've ever seen before, together. Of
course we can add and change terms. If we made this x squared, that changes the
behavior again. What if I made this x cubed instead? Everything makes these
little, minute adjustments in the middle of the graph here. That's pretty cool.
Now I wonder, I just changed one exponent. What if I change this first one? The
exponent of the leading term. Wow, now this graph is completely different. Once
again changing the degree of the polynomial, seems to really change the overall
behavior. What if I make this sign negative? Well that's really interesting, oh
my gosh. Clearly changing different terms in polynomials, especially the
leading term, the term at the highest power has major affects on the graph. I
think this merits some more exploration. In this lesson we're going to
investigate the overall appearance of different polynomial functions in terms
of how they look when we're zoomed way, way out, and when we're zoomed in on
the middle of the graph. In particular we're going to see where these functions
intersect the x axis. And how this relates to factors in routes of
polynominals. I'm really exicted about the content of this lesson.